今日はよろしくお願いします
五十三番目です ［外国語］大変わかりやすい偈だと思います
［外国語］というのは
この花をまとめて集めて［外国語］マラーというのは首輪のことで
花を集めてこの美しい花輪を作るんだ
インドでは今もこの花をね
摘んで輪にするんです
して それを使うんですね
体につけるものになってますからね
日本では体につけることをたまにするんですけど
一般的なのは飾っておく
花を飾っておく場合もそう簡単ではありませんし
これ誰にもできる作業でもないんですね
やっぱりそれなりの能力ある人が
職人の人が花をちゃんと選んで
それで合わせて立てて
大変立派な作品は作るんです
これは誰にもできるという仕事ではありません
花の花輪を作るにしたってまた同じことで
何でもかんでもいいんだからといって
花を糸でつなげたんだからといって
そういう立派な作品にはなりません
花一個一個は 大体花輪を作る場合はでっかい花を選ぶんじゃなくて
すごい小さな花を選ぶんですね
花が小さくて そんな派手な色もない
また変わりのある花 特別に選ぶんです
体に首にかけておくんだからね
またそれぞれ体にも大変薬効果もあるし
ですから もう何でもかんでも使うということではないんです
大体主に使うのはこの白色のジャスミンとかね
またジャスミン それと同じ形のまたすごい小さな花もありますので
そういうものを集めて
すごい微妙に針で糸でつなげておくんです
それは日本ではそういう習慣ないんだから
わからないかもしれませんだけどね
向こうではインドではやっぱりこの花自体もやっぱり薬物効果がありまして
薬物と言っても悪い意味ではなくて
すごい精神的にね 穏やかにする効果がありますし
そのかわりにすごく体によろしいし
だからそういう花を選んで花輪を作ると
ということで 日本で考えていれば
もう花を生けることですね
花を生けることにしたっても
やっぱりただ単に何も技術は身についてない人は
ただ高い花を買っただけでは全然綺麗には見えないんですよ
腕がよくできる人なら
ごく普通の安い安い 単純シンプルな花であろうとも
かなり美しく それは生けることはできるんです
そういうことで ただ花だけではすごいということじゃなくて
そこでいかにそれを組み合わせるのかということが大事なことです
その人間の即席にあるこの出来事をにて
それを例えてお釈迦様が「エーワンジャーテーナマッテーナ」生まれてきた人間が「カッタッバンクサランバホン」あの善行為をいっぱいするべきであると
それでこの人間で生まれたならば
何をするべきかという質問をすると
だったら善行為をしなさいということは答えですね
この偈では はい どうぞ
こちら前に来てください
それであの 生まれてきた人間はどうするべきかというね
質問に この偈の答えは
だったら良い 良いことをしなさいよと
すごいあのわかりやすいと思いますけどね
だからわかりやすいんだから
もうわざと無視するということもありますけどね
私たちはもっとすごいことを知ってるんだぞと
まあまあ そういう人の道は決まってますからね
すごいことを知ってる人々はね
ろくなところに結果には結果は得られませんし
すごいことを知ってるんじゃなくて
真理っていうのはとてもシンプルで理解できるものなんです
このシンプルで理解できるものが理解しないんだから
難しいことを探していくんだからね
それはもう勘違いしていますね
頭はいいと それは逆なんです
無知なんですね あまりにも無知で
このまあ自画自賛したいんですね
俺はこれも知ってる あれも知ってると
でもあなたの行く道はどこかというと地獄だよと
だから地獄に行くためには
そんな偉いことを知らなくてもね
ただふざけてバカなことしたっても行けるんだから
お互い様 苦労した人と苦労しなかった人は一緒に地獄で楽しむことになりますけどね
物事をすごいシンプルで見る人なら
自分の人生は成功するんですね
ですから 人間に私は人間として何をすればよろしいかと疑問がある場合は
もうぐちゃぐちゃ考える人にとってはなかなか答えが出てこないんですよ
例えば商売の場合は 自分で自分で自営業をやった方がよろしいか
もう会社に勤めればよろしいか
会社ならどんな会社がよろしいか
仕事ならどんな仕事を選んだ方がよろしいとかね
もう家作るんだったらどこら辺の場所がよろしいかとか
そんなことではもう決して答えが出てこないんですよ
大体みんなそういうところに足を引っ張られているんですね
勉強するにしても 何を勉強すればよろしいかとかね
まあ必死でもう苦労して
あれこれやと考えるし
考えすぎちゃって 結局何も選ぶことをできなくなっちゃって
ろくに勉強もできなくなる
どんな会社がよろしいかと
ずーっと選びながら考えながらも選んで選んでいく人にとっては
どんな会社にも合格することはできなくなっちゃうんですね
これはもう私が知っている限りはものすごいもう百パーセントの事実なんですね
偉そうなことでも なら何でもいいのに
でもそんな仕事をやりたくない
ああいう仕事もやれと来ないとか
私はもうこういう仕事をしたいんだ
そう言って会社にそこでもう試験を受けたら見事に落第する
それで道がなくなっちゃって
自分が入りたかった会社には落第したんだと
他の仕事もできないし
なぜならばそちらに興味はいかないんだから
一生何か嫌なことで生活しなくちゃいけない羽目になるんだ
だから偉そうなことを考えちゃうと
もう道が決まってますよ
大失敗して不幸になるんですよ
だからもう人生っていうのは
ものすごいシンプルに単純にしなくちゃいけないんです
単純にシンプルにする人こそ知恵があるんですよ
だから この生きる知恵があるのかないかってわかる方法っていうのは
ただそれだけのことなんですね
あれこれと人生っていうのはすごい複雑だったら
もう無知っていうことはもうはっきりしているんですね
それから失敗するということもはっきりしているんです
だから このブッダのこの言葉から見ても
やっぱり答えがすごいシンプルなんですね
人間として私は何するべきかというだったら良いことをしなさいよと
それで答えが全部まとめているんです
良いことは何ぞやとか
また考える必要ないでしょうね
その場でその場でその場で良いことをすればよろしいでしょうに
そう見てみると その場でその場でやっていることは全部嫌なことばっかしで
間違っていることばっかしで
腹が立つことばっかしで
それだったらもうまとめてみても
この人はもう人間生きながらゴミですよと
すぐ分かりますよ この我々毎日やっているこの小さな小さな小さなことが
それは良いことになるようにやればいいし
そこで仏教の側からはね
まあ随分そういうところでは判断するんですよ
別に大胆なことをやっているかないかと見てないんです
たとえ電気のスイッチ入れたっても
そこはどういうことかと
ちょっと見れちゃうと
もう見るとわかるんですね
ただ単にもうマンネリでスイッチを入れたんだと
必要かないかと考えていないんだと
それだけのこと なるほど
この人の人生は役に立たんぞと
本人にも他人にも ちょっとしたことで見えるんですよ
なぜかって そちらにその人の思考が見えるんだから思考がないんですね
ただ決まりだから動くんだから
もうこれは犬猫とは全然変わりがないんです
そこで人生全体でもそうなるんです
その真理に逆らうことはできない
そんなことしたって私はやるとかやりますよとかね
やるときもやりますけど
同じことをやるんです
あまり意味がないんです
ですから この人生についてすごくシンプルに考えた方がよろしいし
我々は何をするべきか
どのように生きるべきかということだったら
善行為をしなさいと それだけの答えなんです
だから善行為は何ぞやと見くんじゃなくて
この日々毎日やっている小さな小さな行為は
すごく善行為になるようにと
気をつけてやれば それで全体的な良い人間になってしまうんです
すごい得難い難しいことじゃないんです
誰にでも実現できる 成功した人間になれる
簡単に そういう教えなんです
そこでクサランバフンっていうのは
仏教ではこの善行為には言葉 2つあります
1つはクサラ もう 1つはプンニャなんですね
悪行為にも言葉 2つあります
もう 1つはクサラ もう 1つはパーパなんですね
そこでプンニャということは
日本訳するともう功徳という訳になっちゃうんですね
一応漢字ではそんな意味があるかどうかちょっとわかりませんだけど
パーパは罪なんですね
クサラは善で アクサラは不善なんですね
それで 善と功徳は何なのかと
不善と悪は何なのかとね
罪は何なのかと ちょこっと理解した方がいいんじゃないかなと
4種類があるんです 善行為と功徳
それから不善 行為と罪
でわかりやすい順番で言うと
まず罪って何なのかというのは
これは犯罪なんですね
罪というのは だから罪を犯してはならないというのは
そんなのはもう言う必要もないんですよ
犯罪を犯してはならないと
それをもうただのもう無駄ですよ
言うことさえも そんなのは当たり前なんです
人は犯罪を犯すべきではありませんとかに
だからこのそういう当たり前のことまで間違っちゃうと
これがもう罪で 悪行為で犯罪ですね
人殺すことやら嘘を言うことやら
人を騙すことやら詐欺やることやらね
そういうの犯罪でもやってはならんということは当たり前で
不善というのはもうもっと大きいんですね
良くない行為といえば
いわゆる犯罪には入らないんだけど
不善行為はあるんです
不善行為はすべて不善行為の中にすべての犯罪も入ってます
犯罪といえばもう項目が小さいんですね
不善といえば項目がすごく大きいんですね
不善という項目の中に
犯罪も一部として入っている
だからこの単語を 2つも使わなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんですね
犯罪を起こしている人だったら
これはもう当たり前やってはいけないということをやってるんだから
そこは別なところで 問題はこのどんな人でも宗教と関係あってはなくても
犯罪ぐらいは気をつけるんです
犯罪を犯す人っていうのは
まあ法律的な犯罪を犯す人っていうのは
まあそれほど多数ということではないんですけどね
では それで良い社会を築けるかというと
それじゃないでしょうね
大体ほとんどの人々は法律を守って
法律的な犯罪を犯さないでは生活をしている
だから社会は随分安全だと
立派な社会ですよということにはなりませんね
だから犯罪を起こさないということだけでは足らないんですよ
結構起こしてますけど
法律では捕まりません
それだけの話 証拠不十分とかね
あるいは隠れてやったとかね
仏教ではもう隠れてやったっても
犯罪は犯罪で 詐欺をやったらそれは犯罪で罪で
バレてもバレなくても悪結果は出てくるんだと
他人にバレるバレないかということは全然関係ないんです
なぜならば 他人にバレる
ただ警察が調べるだけのことで
警察はこの罪に適した罰を与えることはできないでしょうね
法律では 法律ではもうそれなりの刑法がありまして
まあそれにも適したものが何とかするだけのことで
なぜ法律家に言っているのは
もう確実にこの厳罰するんじゃなくて
できるだけ手柔らかくもうということにもあるんだから
で 裁判やってる人々も
もうとにかくもう法律である罰をギリギリまで安く
という気持ちはまるっきりないんです
どうすればその人の罪が軽くなるのかということで考えているんです
だから警察にバレてバレることで
罪を償ったことにはならないんですよ
そんなのは何の意味もないんです
3ヶ月間刑務所にいたんだからといってね
何の意味もないんですよ
刑終わったんだから もう普通の社会人であるとかね
それでは何も意味がない
すごい罪を犯したっても
到底 3ヶ月  3年とかね
5  6年とかね それでもう刑終わってまあ堂々と出てくる
そこで刑務所で何やったかというと
何の苦労もなし もうただで 3食食べて
もうよく安全した環境でよく面倒見てもらって生活しているだけの話でしょうしね
それで罪を償ったと思っちゃうと
これはすごい勘違いなんです
だからこの犯罪はバレてもバレなくても悪い結果にはなります
しかし 自分が犯罪は犯してないということで立派な人間にはならないんですよ
それだったら人間みんな立派なんですね
だからその問題がお釈迦様がこの不善という犯罪を起こしてはならんというのはもう話にならん
そんなのは 不善を犯すな
するなよと 不善行為するなよという大きなカテゴリに入れてるんですね
不善行為っていうのは
それはもうもう人が不幸になる行為全てなんですね
で パーリ語のクサラクサラっていうのは
このクサラっていうのは匠という意味なんですね
アクサラっていうのは匠じゃないということなんですね
だから匠ないといえばどんな意味でしょうかね
なんか単語ありますかね
まずいとか 下手くそとか
下手くそとかね まあ大体まあ下手くそぐらいのね
まあそういう行為するなよと
下手くそもあんまりちょっとそんな意味が通じてないんですね
不器用  不器用 だからまだまだなんかもう一つ何か単語あればありがたいんですけどね
まあクールな単語で言えば上手と下手なんですけどね
まあ肯定的ではまあもう日本語である匠という言葉
すごい立派な単語なんですけどね
で そちらの反対の言葉でね
だから不器用で下手で失敗ということですね
よくあの なんていうか
不良の人たちは美学では半端なことをするなって
ヤンキーの人たち  単語がないということは大変な問題なんですよ
だからこの自分を育てることできなくなっちゃうんですよ
痴絶  何？ 痴絶 幼稚の幼という字と
まずいというか 絶っていうのは
ん？ 痴絶っていう  使う？ 拙い
拙い？ 拙い  それでこの不善行為という拙い行為かもしれませんけど
その場合はもう人がやる全ての行為入るんですよ
朝起きることも行為であって
そこからずっと一日生きていて
寝ることも行為なんですよ
何かを行為をしているんですよ
で 考えることも行為なんですね
夢見ることさえも行為なんですよ
だから自分の意識が絡んでいるものはすべて行為なんです
まあ行為に入らないのはこの心臓ごとぐらいとかな
まあ別にそれはもう関係なく動いてるんだからね
まあそれ以外人間やってることっていうのはね
全部意思が絡んでるんです
この意思が絡んでいる行為
朝起きることも行為 顔を磨くことも行為
顔を洗うことも行為 歯を磨くことも行為
掃除 洗濯することも行為
料理作ることも食べることも皿洗うことも全て行為
喋ることも行為 考えることも行為
人生っていうのは行為のもう連続なんです
行為しないではいることはできないんです
行為止まったっていうことは死んだっていうことだからね
寝ても行為しているんだよ
夢見たりするんだから
だからそれは不善行為してはいけないんだと
だから罪とはすごく違うんです
意味は 罪は犯罪だからね
それそっちやってるわけじゃないんです
人は不幸になるのは罪よりも不善行為なんです
罪っていうのはもう大胆な行為で
そっちをやれるもんじゃないんです
あまりにも大胆な行為だから
もしかするとそれによって
その反動で良い人間になる可能性もあります
本題はこの不善行為なんです
それがずいぶん軽く見ているんだからね
仏教の順番はそんなに罪が罪を大げさに考えている世界じゃないんです
不善行為はすごい大げさに考えるんです
一応それがブッダの立場なんです
で 犯罪認めているわけじゃなくて
そんなのも悪いと言うためにブッダが現れなくてもいいでしょうに
どんなバカにもそれぐらいこと言えるでしょうに
[咳]ブッダが現れたということは
もうその一般の人々にはまるっきり発見できない真理を発見して語ることでしょう
認めるか認めないかということは
それはそれぞれ皆様のご自由で
あの  誰かの それでもアメリカ人が書いてる何か本を読んでそれを理解するというならば
それはそれでよろしいんですけど
一応ブッダはそういうことを言っているということでも
何か頭の隅にでも置いておいた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
犯罪行為っていうのはそんなに大げさに取ってない
それぐらいのことはどんな人にも説明できる
犯罪は悪いんだと犯罪を起こしている人さえも言ってるんだから
それにブッダが現れなくても
そこら辺でいろいろ法律を破って生計を立てている人々いるでしょうに
話してみてください よく説教しますよ
これはダメ あれはダメとかね
この借金取り立ての人々も人を脅してお金も返してもらいますけど
すごく犯罪 どこまでやったら法律に
触れるかとは知ってますよ
だから体は触れません
言いたい放題なことはあれこれで言ってもとことん脅す
音を立てたり足を踏んだりしてものすごい大騒ぎするんですけど
家にある例えば花瓶ぐらいでも取って破って壊そうとはしないんです
だから だったらそういう悪いことをして生計を立てている人でも
もう犯罪は何なのか知ってますよ
嫌がらせはとことんするんだけど
もう警察にも何することもできないんです
証拠不十分になるんです
そういうわけで 何が言いたいかというと
この犯罪は良くないということぐらいはもう犯罪者も知ってるんだから
それがブッダがそれを教えているのか
そんなブッダがなくても見えるもので
お釈迦様で悟ったブッダしか言えないところは
この不善行為の世界なんです
人間が不幸になるのは
こういう犯罪云々ではなくて
この行為の問題であると
行為自体が不善行為であると
そこで善行為しなさいと
行為といえば もうずっと人生は全部行為なんですね
だから 小さな小さな行為でも
一言葉を喋るとかね 階段を上るとか
階段を下りるとかね こういうどんな行為でも善行為にならなくちゃいけないんですよ
巧みにやらなくちゃいけないんですよ
良い結果が得られるように
そこで単語は 4つなるんですね
だから反対の場合は 犯罪に対する反対の言葉は功徳なんですね
で 功徳っていうのはあえて行っている良い行為なんですね
それは日常生活とは関係なく
もうあえてやっている良いこと
日常でも忙しいのに あえて時間を作ってボランティアをするとかね
自分の収入はもうなんとかなんとか間に合ってきてるだけなんですけど
あえてもうお金をなんとかなんとか節約して人を助けてあげたりするとかね
そういうあえてやっている行為がもう功徳行為というんですね
それで犯罪したらもうもういきなり不幸になると同じく
功徳行為すると必ずその人がもうどんどんもう幸福になります
が それだけでは良い人間にはなりません
犯罪は行わなかった 犯罪しなかっただけで良い人間にもなれないし
功徳をしているんだからといってね
1年に一回ぐらい何か巡礼に行くとか
会社クビになったら 88 箇所を回るとか
年金払うは忘れたと分かったらもう議員辞めてまあ 3ヶ月とか修行するとかね
それで良い人間になるということはないんです
決してやったことは悪いことじゃないんですよ
3ヶ月とかもうどこかにあのもう道場に入ったとかね
会社でなんか横領して見つけたと
バレたと それで仕事を一旦辞めて
もう 1年ぐらい隠れている
どこかの道場で それからまたノコノコと社会に出る
まあ一応日本の社会では大体それぐらいのことしか考えてないんですけどね
で 残念なことにはブッダはちょっと違うことを言うんですよ
それでブッダの場合はやっぱりこの善行為じゃなくて
この功徳行為 まああえてやってる特別な行為というのは
それは結果があるんですけど
もうただそれだけで自分の人生全体的に改良したことにならないんですね
で 確実にそれで人生成功するということでもないんです
功徳行為だけでは 確実に成功を収めたければ
まあ善行為をしなくちゃいけないんです
功徳行為じゃないんです
善行為っていうのは もうずっとやっている行為は善行為になるようにしなくちゃいけないんですね
朝起きる瞬間からもう寝る瞬間まで
慣れてくると夢を見ても悪い夢は見ないようになります
夢の中でも悪行為はしないと
不善行為はしないということになるんです
そこでも智慧が働くんです
だから善行為するためには
このもうアホでバカではできるものじゃないんです
ただマンネリで あの人やるんだから
じゃあ嫌なんですけど
俺もやるとか それではもう良い人間じゃないんです
だからいかに真似してカッコつけるのかという主義がありますね
あれひょこっと見て もうカッコつけてやることの真似だけする
それは何よと わからない
それではもう悪のまんまで悪いんですよ
無知のまんまで だから朝から晩までやってる行為
ちっちゃな行為一個一個すごい巧みに良い結果になるようにということを気をつけてやると
それがいつでも観察能力は必要になるし
ただバカで行為してあっても
それはそれ自体悪行為です
何も考えないで何かしたって
善行立てたってもね ただの悪行為だけで何のこともないんです
それ気持ち入っているのか
何考えているのかっていうね
それすごく大事なんですね
そういうことがやっぱりこの善行為するぞと思っちゃうと
確実に知恵っていうものはついてくるんですね
だから微妙にでも失敗はしません
人生は そういうことで
この偈で言っているのは
この善行為しなさいと
功徳を積みなさいではないんです
善行為といえば 無料に無限にやりますからね
功徳といえば もうもうほとんど項目決まってます
いいことって何やといえば
人助けることとかなんとかとかね
すごいちょろい簡単単純なリストですからね
それだけで十分かと 全然十分じゃないんです
だから生まれてきた人間が何するべきかと聞けば
私は何をすればよろしいかという簡単な答えですよね
善行為しなさいと そちらにはしっかりした真理が入っている
それはブッダの知恵で言っていることです
それだけのことです 話は今日は
それは認めないでね 格好つけてね
頑張るのはよくよく見えますけど
私にもね でも先も見えてます
怒りで 憎しみで 競争心で
かっこつけたくて それ自体でも少し汚れているし
結果はないんだそうともわかっているし
だからこの 知恵っていうのはやっぱり必要なんですね
善行為するためには この善行為する人っていうのはすごい面白いんですよ
付き合ってみたってものすごい面白い
もうどんな微妙なことにしたっても何か知っているというかね
ただ箸を置くということにしたっても
もう正しいやり方あるんですよ
みんな知らないんです
でもただ教わったような感じで
機械で置いておく この人はただこのマンネリでやっている
正しいんですよ 置く方見ると
これこれ正しいやり方わかりますけど
同時にこの人は大馬鹿者で
ただマンネリでやっているので
それも見えてくるんです
自分の知恵が働いてないかということは見えますよ
昔聞いた話なんですけど
お嫁に行った人がこのあれ何でしたっけ？定規みたいなものを持ってタオルを畳む時はどれぐらい奥へ畳まなくちゃいけない
そこで測ってやっていると
それだったらものすごい大馬鹿者になるだけで
姑さんにいじめられるんだから
もうすごい心配して もうちょっと畳み方が悪かっちゃうと悪くなると何かすごく嫌味言われるんだということで
で それで姑さんが畳んだタオルとちゃんと定規で測ってみて
自分が畳む時 全く同じように気をつけて畳んで
またちゃんと並んでいるかとまた見て
OK だと そういうことで
何を使いたくないかというと
知恵だけは使いたくないっていう話なんですね
とにかくマンネリになっちゃえばうまくいくんだぞという怠け思考なんですよ
怠け思考を実現するために
精神的にはくたくた疲れる
だから そういう生き方をするお嫁さんにとっては
家はもう地獄そのものでしょうに
掃除をしても雑巾かけても
ものすごい神経がすり減らしてるんだからね
楽しくはないんだ生き方は
なんでそうなるのかというと
善行為だったらこれやりたくない
ただもう言ってることはそのままパターンだけ守りますというえらい態度なんです
傲慢な 強情な 人格は成り立たないんです
毎日あのことで悪人になってしまうんです
それで子育てはもう見事に失敗する
結婚生活はもう見事に失敗する
見事としか言う単語もないんです
あれまで苦労していますから
失敗するために失敗することは簡単なのに
だからもう自分の自己破壊になって失敗するんだから
見事としか言わなくちゃいけないんですね
そこまでは普通は結果ないんですからね
それはちょっとちょっといい加減であれこれやってやっちゃうと
もうみんなもう全部うまくいかないし
自分の人格までそんなに壊れてないでしょうね
失敗するのは簡単ですからね
これは見事に失敗する
もうどうしてもどうすることもできない
もう 自分まで自殺することになるんだからね
日本の社会だけに限ってその説法するならば
その現象というのはすごい明確に見えてくるんです
はい そのお嫁さんは姑さんとトラブルをおかしくないから
姑さんの意図に合うように頑張ってるっていう
それは何て言うか そんなに悪い
なんかうまくやっていきたいという
そういう気持ちはあるんじゃないでしょうかね
だからそれダメと言ってるんです
それでは失敗するんだよと
昔ですね 禅のお坊さんが泥棒が人のものを取れば
もうそれで泥棒だと でお釈迦様の真似して座禅をすれば
もうこれはもうもう形をね
真似すればもうこれは善行為になるんだ
で その人もお釈迦様を真似をしたいと
中身はちょっとよくわかってないかもしれないんだけど
真似をするということはいいことだと思って
ただ真似だけをするということで善行為になるんじゃなるんだよと
その禅のお坊さんはおっしゃってたんですけど
長老の今のお話だと それはそのお釈迦様の真似をしようという側面は
非常に気持ちとしてはいいんじゃないかと思うんですよね
だけど内容がわかってなくて
ただ形だけ真似するっていうのは
これはダメだよということのように聞こえたんだけど
その辺はさっきの姑さんとお嫁さんの関係とちょっと似てるんじゃないかなと思って
今どういうことかな  似てますけど
だから今一生懸命それがダメって言ってるんです
それではうまくいかないんだと
肉体の形を整えても ダメだと
はっきり言えば人のものを取ったら泥棒でしょ
お釈迦さんの真似したらそれも泥棒なんですよ
ブッダから言えばブッダは泥棒と言うんだからね
はっきりと言ってます
真似する連中はみんな泥棒やと
もっと大泥棒なんですよ
ブッダを盗もうとしてるんだからね
それでそうやって形だけ保った人は誰か人格者になったケースがありますかね
たった一つだけでも ないでしょう
それで私は仕事の先生出したことでも
その方が何でもう知られるようになったかというと
それでもう息苦しくなって
もう神経的に障害を起しちゃって
もうダメになっちゃったんですよ
それで彼女が泣きながら
私はここまで頑張ったんだと
そこまで頑張ったならば幸福になってるはずでしょうに
神経障害まで起こしているんだから失敗でしょ
だから行為が間違ってるんですね
だからそこはもう日本の社会では
これがこの知恵がなくても無事にいけるんだということで
知恵否定していますよ
知恵を否定して この機械人間になる
これは禅であろうと これ日本的には言えば文化的にずっとやっていることなんですよ
だからそういう人々はみんな失敗で
日本で成功している人々っていうのは別所にいるんですよ
例えば職人さんたちはみんなもうそれに成功していますよ
でも年もう同じことを繰り返しているかもしれませんよ
でもそういう人々は別なものを知っているんです
今日もちょこちょことテレビ見たところで
この あの 日本で一人しかないんだと
あの木刀と言うんですか
あのあれ あの刀の形の
木刀ですね  木刀 あれ作るおじいさんがいて
もう九十何歳かな もう昔はもう三十人ぐらい職人がいたんですけど
自分の家でね 自分一人だけで
で そのおばあさんが一つ木刀を見せて
これ一本は十万以上になりますよと自慢げに
あの このテレビから行った人に見せるんですよ
あれを見ただけで で 私がテレビで見てて
これは十万のところじゃないでしょうと
いくらなんでも 十万だよというのは
これはもう最低値段だと思いますよ
ただの木で刀のように作っただけなんですけど
その人を作ったものはそのぐらい価値がある
それただの真似事でできるものじゃないんですよ
で 何年からやっていたんですかというと
まあ小学生か中学生時から始めていたんだと
それでこれもうこの魂ですよ
あの仕事の大事なのはね
だからその中である哲学
ある生き方が隠れているんですよ
そこはすぐわかるんですよ
なんだこの木一本に十万誰が払うのか
私でも必要だったら俺何の文句言わずに買いますよ
これなら十万はもう安いもんやと
そこで同じく誰かが機械で計算しながらコンピューターで計算して同じものを作っても
じゃあ二千円でちょうだいと私は言うんです
それだったら それ以上払えませんよ
それ何が違うんでしょうかと
だから大勢の だから日本にしたっても
巧みな人っていうのはすごい少ないでしょ
まあ例えば日本国っていうのは植民の国で職人の国でしょうね
それでなんとか死なないで
なんとか生き延びているんだから
この世界の中で と言っても
本当に職人っていうのはものすごい少ないんですよ
他みんなただパターンだけ真似る
あまり役に立たない 中国に負けるんですよ
パターンだけ真似るんだから
中国に頼んで品物を作った方が結構安くて出来上がっちゃうんです
昨日はバリカン買おうと秋葉原に行って
ま ところで あの すごく性能が良くて
もう新しいあのニュース
あの 何て言いますか 新しい製品やというナショナルのバリカンがあったんです
で 髪の毛の長さに合わせて何か回すやつもあって
まあいろいろあったりして
で 一万ぐらいなりますけどね
でもちゃんとこれはメイドインチャイナと
ナショナルですけど これはメイドインチャイナと堂々と書いてます
だからあれはもうチャイナで作ったから一万で
もし日本で作ったならば
これは二万飛んじゃうと思いますよ
だから 単なる単純に形だけ
おそらくナショナル会社が設計して
あの中国の工場に出したでしょうね
それで中国の工場はむちゃくちゃもう大量生産するだけのこと
それで一万円では売れると
私は買わなかったんです
メイドインチャイナでもあるし
まあただもう大量生産のものだから
高すぎやと そこで形が古くて
もう新しい新製品でもなく
もうもうもうもうもうもしかするともうそのデザインがもう作らないですと
調べて調べて まあやっぱり日本
日本メイドインジャパンというものがあったんです
それはまあ六千ちょっとでも七千
ぐらいでしたけどね でもあの機能も何もほとんどないんですけどね
じゃあまあこれでいいやと
その場合何を考えたかというと
やっぱり品質というかね
いくらなんでもそれなりに使えるでしょうと
中国で作ったもの 大量生産だから
もう 3ヶ月間でイカれてしまう可能性もあるし
それでせっかく日本から送るお土産にメイドインチャイナとド派手にあると
あまり自慢にもなりませんしね
それはいろいろ考えて
まあでは 6,800円のものは買うそうで
1万円のものはまあいろいろ機能はあったんですけど
それはやめるそうと だからこの何か違うところがあるんですよ
そこを忘れてるんだから
もうダメになってますよ
だからこの世の中でみんなただ形だけ真似ればいいと思ってますけど
それがものすごい勘違いなんです
で 慣れる前まではずっと形だけ真似てもいいんですよ
それはもうただの修行の方法であって
じゃあとにかく訳もわからないんですけど
形だけ守ってやるぞとね
そこで必死になってやりながら
精神的にも優れていると
一人前で師匠が決めるんであって
ただ形だけいくらぴったし真似ても師匠が免許皆伝はしないんですよ
この日本ででも それで十年修行しなさい
15年修行しなさいと言ってはいるんだけど
ちゃんと精神取った人にとっては
2  3年でまあお前まあいいやと
帰れと言うんです だからあれは日本社会でやっていると大きな間違いだと思います
それがこの無知で理解しなくても安全で生きるためにという
こういう腰抜け修行哲学なんですよ
形だけ真似ればもう大丈夫やと
でもそれ形真似るためにはものすごい苦労しなくちゃいけない
それがとんでもない割に合わないんですよ
人生は苦労してかっこいいわけじゃないでしょうに
それ自体でもう失敗でしょうに
だからあの親御さんもただのタオルでしょうに
そこを例取るために ちゃんと自分でそれなりの長さの定規等を作って
それで測って測ってみるというね
もし誰でもあれをやってみると
私はその人はまるっきり相手にしない
もう全然相手にしない
もうあっち行きなさいと
喋ってくるなよと ものすごい面白くないし
そういう人と喋ったらこちらまで神経がなんか嫌になっちゃうんです
だから頭がないってことでね
これだけ人間にとってとんでもない
もうそんなんですよ いくら性格がむちゃくちゃだらしなくても
頭がすっごく動く人っていうのはかなり面白いんですよ
そういう人々は社会ではもう何のことなく楽々に成功はします
だから形っていうのはね
やっぱりもう形を守るために知恵が必要であるならば
形で入る入るのは正しいんですよ
形では入ったんですけど
知恵は繋げてないんだったらもうご苦労さんと
あんたくたびれるぞと
早いうちに だからこちらに来る人々の中でも
もう来た日で知ってます
やる人は だから全然私は何とか言ってあ
そうって終わっちゃいますからね
知ってる人は知ってると思いますけどね
時々予言までする なんとか何とかいう人は
まああとまあ 二ヶ月でしょう
三ヶ月でしょうと 落ちるぞと
恥ずかしいでしょうね
読まれているということは
それで ああ残念だ 我々はそうならないように頑張らなくちゃって
全然そういう気にはなりません
ですから この要は この
まあそういうことで だからこの
そのずっと長い間 もういろんなところで
例えばそういう禅の寺でもそんなことを言うのは
この真相 真意が忘れた時なんですよ
その禅 禅の先生にしても
仏教は何ですか 何とかとか
自分にも教えてあげる能力はないし
もう社会もあまり興味もないし
もうせっかく入ったけど
弟子はどうやって育てればいいかもわからないし
もうまあとりあえず形だけでもいいんだから真似しなさいと言うんじゃんです
だからそういった時点で
まあやっぱりもう もうとっくに死んでるんだと
システムがね そういう証拠なんです
だから初期時代の禅ではそんなことは言ってないんだからね
形だけ真似ればいいかとかね
逆をいって真似るなよと
形はと 禅の初期時代では厳しい
もう形真似ると 守るとその場でバカにされるんだから
その時は何かあったんです
その中国時代のね もう前の時代の初期時代の禅の和尚たちは何か持っていたんです
だから弟子たちが硬く形守っちゃうとぶん殴られる
追い出される そこでその何か持っていたことが消えたところで
本人はどうやって育てればいいかわからないんですね
だったら古いお坊さん
禅師たちが言った通り
ことを本で読んでみて
ではこういうふうに形を守ってくださいと
形になったのはそういうわけなんです
例えば花たてることでも形だけで上手になる
全くダメでしょうに 形だけだったらもうそれぞれ先生に先生作品作るまでじっと作品作る前に花の写真を撮って
それから作品の写真撮って長さを測ってきて
この花はこれぐらいで切ったと
これ これそれのコピーはできるんだけど
価値がないでしょうに
中国でやってる大量生産と同じだから
だから花の稽古も結構何年もかかるでしょ
あんなことになんで何年もかかるんですかね
問題はみんな形だけでいいやと思って入るんだけど
形ではなくて そっちに心があるんだよと
で それわかるためにはすごく時間かかるんですよ
それ最初にわかっちゃえば
もう一週間の修行でもできますよ
自分の作品を作ることは
それから大胆でもういろんなことをもう家の家元のことを破ってでも新しい伝統を作ることまでできるんですよ
あのサーカスありますね
このソ連のあれ ボリショイサーカスとかね
面白いでしょう あれは
もう見たことはないんですけど
テレビ以外はね 動物はいっぱいいろんな面白いことをやっていてね
だから形だけっていうのはそれその程度なんです
馬にクマ クマに犬に猫にライオンに何とか芸をさせると
で 動物がやるんだから驚きますけど
なんで驚くのかって 何もわかってなくやってるでしょうに
形だけ だから面白いんですよ
あんなのはもう 1 日の修行で人間ならできるでしょ
テレビ見たんですけど
なんか最近猫も入ってるんですね
猫っていうのはなかなか芸はしないでしょ
これであの連中は見事に猫に芸を教えちゃって
やっぱり教える側がもうプロなんですね
真相を知ってるんですよ
だから猫でも出てこいと教えてやるぞっていうのは
そういう自信があるんです
非ということを全く聞かない動物は猫で
結構やるんで 面白いことは猫は
それで猫やってるっていうことは
まあもうちょっとしたもうもうもう 3歳の子供にもできます
あれぐらいは なんで 3歳の子供にできるのかというと
頭があるでしょうに だから形だけ真似るっていうのは
そういう まあそんな程度の能力
テクニックなんですよ
で そうなんかやってることを見てもね
まああの どこかに座って見せるとかね
あるいは小さななんとかでいうと
ぐるぐる回って見せるとかね
そんなことは子供にもできるでしょうに
じゃあこちらに座ってごらんと言ったら座るでしょうに
何の調教もなく じゃあここちょっとぐるぐる回ってみてと言って回るでしょうね
でも象にやらせるの大変難しいんですよ
なぜかというと 頭を使わないんだから
だからこの日本文化では
そのあの難しい道を選んでいるんです
それで人生はダメになっちゃうと
ものすごい神経がね 障害を起こしちゃうんですよ
面白くない えらい緊張する
タオルを畳み 叩きながら畳みながら
怯えている だからそういうところで
ちょこっと知恵が働いたならば
なんでタオル畳むのかと
それだけのことなんですよ
ただ洗ったままでポンと何か放り投げちゃうと見た目が悪いし
もうジワジワシワシワばっかしで
なんか気分良くもうすぐに使う人は気分良く使えないし
もうどうせ洗濯機で洗うんだから汚れはそのままでしょ
だから洗ってるっていう気分もないし
昔私のところに来てお泊まりした子供
私はちゃんともうタオルとか洗っておくんですけど
まあそんな自分使うもんだから別にもう
とか何とかはしない ある日子供にもこの子タオル使ってくださいって言ったら
そいつは嫌がるんですね
では母親に言ったんですね
なんだあの態度だと 母親がね
あれで洗ってないと思ってるんだから
洗わなくてもいいんだから畳んでおいてください
母親が言ったんです そいつは何も文句なく使いますよ
次はそれ試してみたんです
洗ってないタオルをちゃんと丁寧に畳んで
じゃあこれは君のタオルだからと
すごく気分よくそれを取って使っていたんです
まあそれからもう洗おうか洗わないか
とにかく畳んでおくんです
その子が来ると だからまあそこら辺は理解して
例えばもうそんなにね
もうタンスとかね いくらでもあるわけでもないし
もうそこでスペースはすごい少ないでしょうし
だったらその新しいお嫁さんが小さなスペースでよくたくさんタオルを詰めて
もっと余裕があるようにした方
何とかする そうすると姑さんの真似する必要ないでしょうに
そうすると いえ うちでは
でもこの方がたくさんタオルを詰めますよと
取り出しは簡単だよと言ったらもう文句ないでしょうに
お母さんただ畳んだだけで能じゃありませんと
これ引っ張り出すと全部落ちるんだからとかね
まだこのやり方では 10枚しかこの場所に入りませんだけど
私のやり方 15枚入りますよと
こちらでちょこっとした花でもつけますよと
空いてる場所でと言えばね
こっちお嫁さんの勝ちでしょう
それには必要な何でしょうかね
この頭ですよ その方が楽でしょうに
楽しいでしょうに そんなもんで
だからこの無知でよろしいというね
無知は大事な大財産のごとく守るぞというね
この生き方 これはもうものすごい邪教です
仏教から見れば恐ろしい邪教なんです
無知こそ人間に対する偉大なる損である
それこそ恐怖だと 無知ほど怖いものはないんだぞと
堂々とお釈迦様おっしゃってるんです
だったら智慧ほど財産もないんです
智慧ほど幸福もないんです
だからもう形ではなくて
どうやって智慧が開発するのかという
ここがポイントなんですね
そのために善行為しなくちゃいけないんです
ある別な新興宗教のグループのある女性といったってまあおば様でしたけどね
一緒にどこかで行った時は
かなり昔 学生の時の話で
もうえらいこの法華経に凝っちゃって
まあまあ新興宗教のグループの方でね
で やっぱりそれなりに長い間付き合っていたっていうことは
それなりに面白いんですよ
やってることは別に 私はもう全然もう変変とか変な新興宗教だから
あまり気にしなかったんですけど
あの人々はそれだけで終わっていたいたわけじゃないんですね
どんなものに対しても
何か正しいやり方 もっと格好つけていいやり方っていうことをずっと考えてるんですね
ただバス停で並んでいても
ただ並んでるわけじゃなくて
それなりにちょこっと何か考えて並んでる
そこが非常に気に入ったんですよ
何でももう形でやるんじゃないんだと
まあかなり形而上学的な神秘的な解説はしていたんですけど
もう変な変とこ 変な宗教的な神秘的な解説するためにでも頭使わなくちゃあかんのかな
そこでその方と一緒にこの駅で
あの私も結構足が速いんだからね
まあもうかなり早く この人もなんとか苦労して一緒に来るんですけど
その階段上がっている時でも一言は言ったんですね
私はね このいろんな人を階段上るときよく見ているんだと
あ そう それで見てください
みんな足を入れてないんだと
階段に かかとはもう浮いてるんですね
ちらっと見たらなるほど
だからそれでまた私はその人の観察で気に入ったんです
ただバカみたいに階段上がるんじゃなくて
本人がきちんと足全体につけて
もう階段を上がっている
そこを見たら 他の人はみんなもう牛
お尻を叩かれた牛の連中みたいに
もうただ登るだけで もうろくに足を踏んでないんですよ
階段に 一番危ないのは女たちなんですよ
だって靴履く場合はいかに履きにくいかということ
決まりでしょ いかに歩きにくいか
健康に悪いか そういう基準で決めているんだから
女っていうのはもう大体もう 30歳になってくると体がボロボロガタガタでしょうね
あれがこのいかに骨に悪い靴ないのかという
それだけで この間もある女の靴を見たら
まあこれデザインというか
もうおしゃれやと思ってるでしょうね
でもあんなものよく歩けるな
この女と思ったんですよ
もう完璧に足に悪いんです
倒れるんですよ あれでは
だから倒れるんだけど
そこは工夫して もうタイトロープウォーキングあれなんて言いますか
綱渡り ああいう風に訓練しなくちゃいけないんですよ
毎日歩くたびに それで倒れないようにと
そういう女が足の半分ぐらい入れて階段を上がったり下りたりすると
まあ若いんだから倒れないんだけど
その分あの衝撃は肉体で骨で受けなくちゃいけないんですよ
それから一生病院帰り
このこのハイヒールというかね
そういうものなんかね
階段で例えば下りる時はかかとだけでしょうに
考えただけでぞっとしますよ
だからまあちらっとしたあの女性の観察で
そういう世界がちゃんと見えてくるんだから
面白いんですよ 別に別に悪口言ってるわけじゃない
その方は本当に真面目に自分の宗教を信仰していたんだから
すごい性格も良くて もうかなりおせっかいで
みんなにガチャガチャガチャガチャいろいろなことを言うし
それはよく役に立つしね
だから本人がそのある法華経の信者さんになっちゃって
それと同時に自分も人生を考え直す
見直すというね ところになって
この微妙なところでもチェックする
階段上る時はどのように登ればよろしいかと
だから本人がちゃんと足全体階段につけるようにということを気をつけて登るんですよ
だからそのちっちゃな行為でも
善行為なんですよ それによって頭が浮くんだから
機能するんだから ただのマンネリじゃないんです
だから階段走って登ろうか
それは構いません 私から言えばね
あるいは階段段段も飛ばして登ろうか
そんな勝手で元気な奴らが何やってもいいんだけど
その行為は善行為ならなくちゃいけないんです
ただ 若い男連中は三段階飛ばし飛ばして行って
そこでこけちゃうと大失敗なんですよ
こけないでしっかりと飛んでいったならば
それで OK でしょうね
それにはちょこっとした知恵が必要なんです
別にみんなもうちゃんと丁寧に各階段の全部踏んでいかなくちゃいけないって
そんな話はないんです
だから いかに巧みに自分の行為をするのかっていうことがポイントなんです
巧みっていうことは失敗しないってことなんです
だから 生まれたきた人間は何するべきかというと
だったら善行為しなさいと
功徳を積みなさいではないんです
功徳っていうのはリスト決まってますからね
お布施することをやら
人に優しくすることやら
嘘言わないことやらとかね
それリスト決まってます
善行為の場合はない リストは全ての行為
だから善行為する人はもう確実に成功するってことになるんです
それで知恵が開発する
で 例えば人を助ける ボランティアするっていうことにしても
それは功徳行為なんですね
だってあえてやってますからね
日常忙しいなのに時間もないのにあえてやっていることだから
これはもうはっきりとした良いことで
でもそれでマンネリになってくると
あの力が減っていくんですよ
あまり効き目がなくなっちゃうんです
だからボランティアでも毎日毎日やりながら
それでまた知恵が開発していくならば
それすごい成功なんです
大体善良いことをしようとしている人々は
功徳をやろうとしてる人々っていうのは
どこかで疲れて辞めちゃうんですよ
もうやりきれないんだと文句言って辞めちゃうんです
大体辞めるためにずーっとなんか考えてるんですよ
そうするともう立派な善行為でもないし
功徳にもならないし あんまり影響は自分の人格に入ってないんですよ
だから大胆な善行為より
毎日やってる行為全てを巧みに行うことが正しい道であると
それがブッダの言葉なんです
ブッダの答えなんです
いいことをしなさいということは
どんな宗教でも言ってるし
これでも犯罪者に聞いたっても言うんですよ
私はダメでしたけど 君は悪いことするなよと
みんなすごく立派だ思っているのは
この犯罪者にさえ言える説法なんですよ
ブッダの説法はそうじゃないんです
ブッダにしか語れない真理なんです
そこですごいわかりやすく
インドでそこら辺で誰でも花は作ってますよ
みんな使ってますから
特に収入のない人々は
もう他の仕事のない人々は
山に入ってあちこち花を摘んできて
どこかに腰をかけて 糸でちゃんと丁寧に花を作って
それを売って生計を立てている
その場合はもうすごい
普段は全然小さな花だから
もう何にも役に立てませんし
もう立てる時も使えないんだからね
その場合は枝丸ごと使わないとね
小さな花がついている場合は
あれって結構自然破壊ですよ
例えば桜の花でもね もう家の中で立てようと思ったら
枝を丸切り持ってこないと
花 1本では何もできんだからね
それで枝ごとに切っちゃうと
これはもう破壊ですよ
それでインドで使うのはもう桜の花
もっと小さい花なんです
それだったらもう摘むだけだから
木にも何も迷惑はないし
そこは小さな針と糸で
もうこんな熱い かなり厚みのある花輪にするんです
首輪ですけどね  [背景音楽]だから一本一本の花について考えて
大きさ形考えて もう例えばハイライトする部分
この花輪の真ん中の取ることと
ここ肩に来るところとかね
そこら辺はちょっとアクセント入れなくちゃいけない
アクセント入れる場合はどんな花使うのかとかね
それで考えて きれいな価値のある価値のない花から価値のある花輪を作ると
そういう感じで まあ一個一個はどうったこともないんだよと
でもまとめたらすごいんだぞという生き方をしなくちゃいけない
階段上る時はしっかり上るっていうことは別にどうったことはないんです
それであなたすごい人格者と言わなくてもいいんですけど
その生き方だったら 人生は本当に人格者なんです
カップを洗った後も もう何て言いますか
あの洗い場を綺麗にしたっても
もう一つ微妙に微妙に考えているならばね
そういう生き方で立派な人間になりますよということは
まあブッダの言葉だからね
これはもう間違いなしですよ
やってみてください はい
それでまあもう二つやる時間はないんですけどね
それで終了したいと思います
今日勉強するところは
この四つの単語があるということ
功徳と罪 罪っていうのは犯罪
功徳っていうのはもうあえてやっている良いこと
ボランティアに行くとかね
地震が起きたらそちらにさーっと行って何とかして助けてあげるとかね
そういうあえてやってる
だからあえて善行為するべきっていうのは当たり前で
犯罪を起こしてはいけないっていうことは当たり前で
それぐらいのことはブッダでなくても誰にでも言える二つですよ
ブッダにしか言えないのは善行為
不善行為なんです 行為は善行為にしなさいと
クサラとアクサラ その四つあるんだって単語はね
と覚えておいてください
クサラアクサラとプンニャとパーパ
はい 終わりです いろいろ知りたいこと
他の質問とかあるならば聞いてみてください
[背景音楽]